at this parks wagon plant in Kaluga
south of Moscow a new car runs off the
assembly line every two minutes VW has
been producing cars here for around nine
years the plant employs five thousand
workers and they're happy with their
employer up to now everything has been
going very well we have a package of
benefits and health insurance it's great
but even though the robots are busy
welding in Kaluga VW Russia is in crisis
it's unit sales have plunged 45% in the
past two years it's a big loss last
spring the automaker cut the number of
shifts from 3 down to 2 a day the
reasons for the crisis are clear the
decline of the ruble the low oil prices
and Russia's high inflation few people
have the money for a new car the head of
VW Russia is expecting the downturn to
last for a while if you read The Masque
commentaries and listen to the
economists of course it's a problem
which is not going to be resolved this
year or the next
so we're bracing ourselves for two or
three lean years Russia and car
showrooms are almost empty of customers
at the moment that's unusual in a
country with so many car enthusiasts the
few customers are pragmatic about the
crisis I have to make sacrifices to be
able to buy a car or not I still have to
drive your car gets old what can you do
with technology Maria damata latest
phenomenon while some automakers like
General Motors are completely curtailing
production in Russia VW is continuing to
invest in its Kaluga plant a new engine
factory opened at the end of last year
at a cost of 250 million euros
a big risk in a time of crisis Russia's
ooook economists significant price rises
and high interest rates forced Fox wagon
to cut back its production here in
Kaluga but the German carmaker still
believes in the long-term prospects of
its commitment in Russia